So good morning,
uh,
valid today.
We have a fun topic,
suicide.
Um,
actually I didn't realize how much interest that is amongst students in suicide.
once we invited a professor from Australia who wanted to teach a course on desks
and suicide,
and I was very concerned that those students who will take it and the class was
full.
So it looks like suicide is a popular topic and I think I know why because when
I was your age or occasionally took her through my mind,
what if I commit suicide?
All right.
So I think thinking about suicide is probably something what crossed many of
yours.
Mine.
Uh,
and therefore hopefully,
uh,
there can be,
will be exciting for you and we'll help you to understand why did you consider
it and why did you did not do it right?
Or Via your,
um,
friends or acquaintances thought about it.
Some of them may have tried,
some of them may have killed themselves.
Anyway,
so this is about suicide.
And as I said already before,
um,
this is a path to baking book.
Uh,
in many ways,
uh,
it's really the first rigorous empirical study and offer social phenomenon.
And they're very curious social phenomenon.
And we were talking about this as the lectured on faults because we tend to
think about suicide.
There's something very personal,
right?
An individual and or right,
if a psychologist is interested in suicide is understandable,
but why on earth as sociologists would be interested in suicide?
It is so rare socially,
fortunately,
uh,
I mean in some societies but in most very rare and it looks like it's so much a
question of individual decision.
So why should um,
a social scientist try to explain it?
So there are times sets for himself a very difficult task and he does it.
Formidably ivy,
we'll show you that he does some spectacular methodological innovations.
Um,
he's kind of offers metal dialogical insights.
What social scientists start excited about even today.
Uh,
uh,
well over a century after he this book.
Okay.
So that's about Swedish side.
And first of all,
I've your ask a few general questions.
Um,
uh,
and the first off all the question is what is suicide?
Then when do v I decide at the death is suicide.
And then also I would like to pose the question,
uh,
what are,
um,
uh,
what are the reasons for social scientists to study it?
And deer came,
give some very good reasons.
And finally I've,
you'll introduce Durkheim's die Balaji of suicide,
the many dirty cams scholars versus struggling with this,
how to make sense of this.
Stype Ologie and I've,
you're sure you have on,
um,
uh,
very hard to do it sort of that are,
he has major,
uh,
types.
Uh,
our ego is the altruistic Annemieke and fatalistic suicide and live you,
we'll talk about each of them in Kern.
Okay.
So let me start with the definition.
And this is tricky by the way.
Uh,
also extremely tricky.
Um,
uh,
when it comes to statistics to figure it out,
what statistics do rapport as suicide,
uh,
um,
people die.
Um,
especially if they do not leave a letter behind.
It's very hard to decide whether that person actually committed suicide or it
was just an accident.
Well,
that are occasions when this is quite obvious.
And I had somebody hanging himself or herself,
uh,
which is a fever that they have of committing suicide of certain type of people
in certain instances.
Right?
And the VA,
how somebody hanged himself makes it quite clear that it was a suicide.
But doctors investigating the cause of death very often are puzzled.
A veteran,
this is suicide or not.
So you clearly have an overdose of sleeping pills.
It's unclear whether it was an accident accidentally.
Um,
you took more blip bills then you should have or whether this was actually a
suicide.
Uh,
so that is,
um,
a lot of problem in studying statistical data about suicide.
Um,
uh,
and the very often,
um,
doctors do make judgments,
uh,
um,
on the social circumstances of the person who committed suicide,
right?
Uh,
they read Durkheim or they have read some social scientists.
They tell these are the kinds of people under the circumstances who,
who commit suicide.
So they go to the scene,
they look at that person,
look at the circumstances.
This is an old man who's wife just passed away very recently.
So that must be of course,
suicide.
All right.
So therefore,
what is suicide is being defined by the circumstances rather than actually,
uh,
by,
the,
uh,
medical reasons.
Okay.
So let's try to struggle a little bit this,
what is suicide under what circumstances can be talking about suicide.
And here is,
uh,
um,
Durkheim's definition.
The term suicide,
right is applied to all cases of deaths resulting directly or indirectly he
positive or a negative act of the victim himself,
which he knows we are produced.
These results,
well,
uh,
looks like a very complicated definition,
but a very full and they're very good volume.
Uh,
and the first point is intention,
right?
Uh,
that in order to call at the s three side,
uh,
there must be intention,
on behalf of the person who commits suicide.
Well,
there's intention can be very,
uh,
um,
well,
uh,
the AME might not be necessarily Saturday structure,
and the AME may be something else.
Uh,
for instance,
uh,
or you can't think about suicide bombers,
right?
Uh,
they don't want to kill themselves.
They want to kill others,
but they use their body as a vapor,
right?
And they explode themselves in order to cause harm to others.
Right?
But that's clearly a case of suicide because they know that they will die as a
consequence of that action.
And therefore it can be called suicide.
Do it,
uh,
is not aimed at the person himself.
Now,
uh,
the how the act of suicide can be in director,
um,
uh,
and in fact in can be,
can be negative.
Um,
sort of you more suicide is a direct and positive action,
right?
Uh,
you jump from the 40th floor,
right?
And then,
uh,
you,
you kill yourself.
You'll take sleeping pills and overdosed and you kill yourself,
uh,
about it can be injured,
act and negative.
I mean,
you can starve yourself to death.
Um,
uh,
and that can be crawled suicide as long as your intention is to kill yourself.
All right?
Um,
so it becomes very tricky.
Uh,
uh,
what do you do with people who are abusing drugs or alcohol?
Right?
Uh,
they may actually die as a result of excessive alcohol or drug drug consumption.
if it is not intentional,
uh,
they don't want to kill themselves.
They just lied,
boozy,
right?
They just like cocaine,
Um,
uh,
Dan,
it is not switch side.
Uh,
there are lots of Russians who have been dying.
Um,
and the last 35 years,
their numbers,
especially,
um,
middle aged Russia,
men were dying like flies because they are drinking too much vodka in the
overwhelming majority of the cases does not suicide,
right?
They are depressed.
They are silly.
They think drinking vodka will have the depression and those results,
they will get liver cancer and they will die,
right?
So it was not suicide.
Uh,
well,
if you lock yourself into your room,
you take sleeping pills and you drink a bottle of vodka in order to kill
yourself,
then it was suicide,
right?
So anyway,
uh,
you have to know the consequences of your action.
You have to know that's what you do there.
Kill yourself in order for your act to qualify as a suicide.
So I think this is really beautiful,
beautiful.
U Dub,
um,
and,
uh,
has been extremely influential,
for,
uh,
social scientists.
As I said,
it makes,
um,
very big challenge to medical investigators who try to determine the cause of
deaths.
Um,
uh,
because,
it's very difficult to establish the intention,
right?
Uh,
uh,
and the most of the cases of suicide,
you cannot be absolutely sure of the intention.
You don't know that,
that this was an accident or whether it was intentional unless the victim of the
suicide Aveo tell you,
uh,
leave selector behind Dallas that I committed suicide.
Okay.
Uh,
now,
uh,
as I said,
it looks life that suicide is very much a very personal action.
All right?
Uh,
uh,
well,
occasionally people talk about that intention to commit suicide when and if they
do so they probably feel not do it right.
Uh,
those who are serious about suicide keep it to themselves and them kill
themselves.
Those who talk about B,
I am suicidal very often simply want to have attention.
Right?
Um,
and then even if they attempt suicide,
you know,
it's off often it's kind of fake,
uh,
the smart enough,
they just take a little overdose of sleeping pill,
but not too much.
And because they already told they are suicidal,
right?
Their friend rushed to the hospital and they've,
you'll be all right.
All right.
So anyway,
uh,
um,
it's a very individual act.
You usually keep your intention to commit suicide to yourself rather than
discussing with somebody else.
And it looks like,
you know,
taking your life away,
um,
uh,
is really,
um,
you were on,
on business.
Um,
so the question is why owners,
people who study society should be interested in these very individual,
very private act and well,
he said,
look,
uh,
look at for instance,
the suicide rate,
how it varies across countries.
And he said that it's tremendous difference in suicide rate across countries
that are countries which really low and the other countries with very,
very high.
So we decided relatively speaking,
I mean,
so his side is a no over the top ranking cause of deaths law in some countries,
you know,
and in certain age groups it can easily enter the top five causes of deaths.
And on top of this,
those countries where people commit suicide tend to be countries where people
committed suicide for a long climb.
It's a very stable indicator.
A Scandinavian countries are wants where usually the suicide rate is reasonably
high.
My native Hungary is a country which for a very long time bus proud of being
number vom in committing suicide.
All right.
Uh,
uh,
well incidentally this is not in very time.
What if I may add to this that were people who were of course you know,
during can inspire it and still in Spanish,
a lot of research on suicide.
He has been challenged on many questions but he still,
you know,
after 110 years the agenda Satcher on suicide research.
If any runoff you become a biologist or sociologist the doctor and want to
conduct research on suicide,
you have to cite their client,
right?
You have to start from there kind if you are studying at this.
But anyway,
um,
there were people would have inspired by him and looked further insight
countries.
And what is interesting that we in countries there are actually gigantic
differences between regions.
There are some regions in this countries with very high and some regions,
some of these countries with relatively loose suicide rates and these are pretty
constant as such.
Uh,
well I had a colleague,
as I said,
you know,
it's Blah or not too parochial for me to refer to Hungary because now hunger is
I think only a number two or three in the world in suicide rate,
but has been number one for a century.
So anyway,
I had a colleague who did that and detailed studying in Hungary about,
so he's side inspired by Durkheim and found that there were certain regions in
the country where the suicide re were particularly high as valley.
It was low and he actually could identify,
uh,
the type of people who committed suicide and the way how they committed suicide
for instance.
And that has been stable for a century as far as it was possible to go back in
statistics,
just to give you an example,
and it feel also help us when we are looking at the deer camp apology of
suicide.
For instance,
he found that,
uh,
you know,
male farmers,
um,
all the male farmers are living in detached forms.
Uh,
when their wife pastors of a unexpectedly women are expected to live longer.
That man,
right?
Uh,
when their wife passes away unexpectedly the typical way,
but men doors,
they hang themselves in the attic.
And this happens again and again.
The tosh farms,
all the man live died.
People grew up and hang themselves,
right?
Uh,
suicide to put in another way is a way of dying,
right?
That are some circumstances in which in certain societies,
uh,
you know,
that this is the unsure to your problem.
That's who commits suicide,
right?
I had the few are men,
you know,
we are usually pretty dumb.
We don't know how to cook.
We don't know how to take care of ourselves.
You know,
you are old,
you are vived died.
So what do you know you'll call miss soy side,
right?
Under certain circumstances,
Anyway,
I think this is a,
uh,
this is why it makes it interesting,
right?
For social scientists that there are interesting social patterns,
cultural patterns,
how people commit suicide.
And you know,
uh,
during can build very calm this as much.
And then he said that are in fact large,
big historical events which do have an impact on suicide rates.
You would think there is a big social Kerman oil,
then suicide rates will go up.
You are wrong.
If that is a big social suicide rate tends to be going down because that is
damson revolution.
People don't commit suicide.
Anyway,
his point is that suicide is a collective phenomenon,
right?
Somehow it is social and the debtor mine as Fmr.
Memnon,
okay.
Now this is the type Ology of suicide and I have been struggling with this and
um,
uh,
people who know much more about Durkheim have been struggling with this type
Balaji.
Um,
and uh,
uh,
what of course I was trying to do as others who are trying to do to do a two by
two table,
right?
And to put these types of suicide in this two by two table there Kime in writing
about suicide seemed to make a distinction between um,
uh,
the question of integration and regulation,
right?
Integration means you know,
how tight the organized a group or society is in which you live.
All right?
And that as a,
I already pointed out,
you know,
in the earlier lecture right there,
it kind of has these idea of normal versus logic.
And I've,
you're talking about this in more detail.
Um,
when the last lecture on,
on their crimes,
uh,
methodology,
he has this interesting idea.
That's what is normal is to kind of tippy car.
I had to put it very crudely.
Normally it's the kind of the average if it is too much or too little,
this is pedological or have more and more.
That is the idea.
So therefore one dimension in which what,
uh,
he,
he uses the type apology is integration,
right?
How Val integrated,
we are into a social group,
the odd n now that can be too high or can be too low,
right?
And War store high integration and too low integration can be the cause of
social pathologies and Vaughn of the social pathology is that you kill yourself.
All right?
Um,
and the other dimension is regulation.
uh,
how much,
how tight,
how rigorous the norms are.
We should regulate your behavior.
Again,
it can't be too high or it can be too low and it feel,
uh,
I fact also that,
apologies,
you know,
if you are obey from,
uh,
the Golden Middle Road,
right?
That's what,
Eh,
you know,
dairy,
calves,
idea of normality is if you are on the golden middle of the road than you are
more and more.
If you deviate,
you're on an abnormal.
This is a very problematic proposition and Durkheim has been challenged.
Now,
the big trouble is,
are these two dimensions independent from each other.
They overlap and it's three hourly.
They are not really how completely independent from each other.
This is why you could not put this into a two by two table,
right?
Uh,
because,
uh,
your,
um,
uh,
some of the types of abnormalities can be only understood in integration or in,
Eh,
in terms of regulation.
But anyway,
I was saying this is probably the best way I can come up with it or end the
dairy.
Admit it should the best way I have read.
Uh,
basically using this to the mansions,
uh,
as,
not,
not as a two by two table sort of topic.
To put it this way,
uh,
it's uh,
that de done a two by two table.
It's like you don't have two dimensions,
all right.
And then you have the types over here,
right?
Too High and too low,
And you have integration,
integration and uh,
uh,
you have regulation
and uh,
high and low and high and low.
This is how you can do it,
right?
You can conceptualize it,
but it's true.
You know,
it doesn't vary within that normal two by two table.
Okay,
well let me start to talk about [inaudible] side,
right?
And therefore,
Eight boys,
the suicide had something to do with it.
Social Integration and it is a case,
then the social integration is too low.
Um,
and he said,
well,
uh,
the more Veekan the globe to which,
or the person will come and sue dotted belong,
the less he depends on them.
Um,
and he caused this egoism,
right?
If you don't,
you know,
you,
you are to yourself and you are not,
do not feel as possible,
uh,
to you own,
grow,
uh,
and uh,
therefore you may be committing suicide.
Um,
again,
you know,
people who are considering suicide,
uh,
just to show,
the lack of ego is man,
the importance of the group.
Uh,
now you may think you have a good enough reason to kill yourself.
You know,
my life doesn't have any purpose.
my boy or girlfriend left me,
so therefore I'd rather kill myself.
And then they say,
well,
I can't really do this to mom,
right?
Uh,
right.
I cannot disappoint by my parents.
Right?
So therefore,
you are not,
you cannot act egoistic,
Ali,
right?
You belong to a group.
And because the tightness,
um,
the solidarity with the globe prevents you to commit suicide.
So in order to act egoistical,
it means that you don't care about others or you don't care first of all about
yourself.
Um,
as such,
now the solidarity can be different.
It can be religion,
it can be family,
or it can be the society.
Um,
and,
uh,
let me speak to this.
If this,
uh,
religion and family or so Satya such offers sufficient solidarity,
then you reel not be likely to commit suicide.
Uh,
okay.
So let me,
uh,
talking about religion and,
and suicide and also,
uh,
a bit about the,
how,
um,
religion and education are linked together with,
so he side there came thus you something really pass breaking.
Yeah.
No,
the statistical technologies were not available.
You really do,
does the logic off Marty,
various statistical analysis,
uh,
he almost does aggregation model to put it this way.
We south numbers,
but that's,
that's the logic of the argument.
And then he's starting to get bad,
but he cross the Jewish exceptionalism.
Uh,
um,
uh,
well this will be,
interesting because the fundamental idea is that in fact,
generally,
uh,
people who are more educated and more likely to commit suicide,
right.
Uh,
there is also a relationship between religion and,
and,
uh,
and so he side Protestants are more likely to commit suicide catalytics,
less likely to commit suicide.
Catholics are less educated.
Protestants are more educated to being more educated than Protestant makes you
more susceptible to commit suicide.
You are use,
but Jews are an exception because joy is suicide rate is generally very low and
Jews are very highly educated.
So that's the Jewish puzzle,
right?
By owners,
highly educated Jews don't kill themselves.
If you are right,
a Lutheran or Presbyterian,
then you are educated.
You kill yourself.
Right?
Why are Jews don't try?
That's the puzzle.
You know,
what is the relationship between education and religion and why our nurse
education leads to higher level of suicide?
Right.
Uh,
okay.
Let me therefore,
uh,
start with this one there.
Um,
as I said,
uh,
he generally new finds that,
that is a higher rate of suicide among Protestant and lower rates among
Catholics and Jews have the lowest suicide rate among the Judeo Christian,
uh,
sphere of,
of the world.
That's what he studied the European countries.
Um,
in fact,
Islamic,
uh,
suicide rate is also,
low.
Uh,
well,
uh,
one possible easy answer would be that,
um,
you know,
there are stricter penalties if you are catalytic and if you commit suicide as
far as you don't commit suicide,
right?
But that's not quite true and were time,
why are you was right.
Um,
in fact,
all religions are against suicide.
No religion aloes suicide.
Well,
Roman Catholics may be a little more,
uh,
rigorous about it.
You know,
uh,
you do not yet at a religious burro burrito.
I think most Roman Catholic piece would not bury who committed suicide in more
standard trees.
Um,
uh,
while,
but I have to stand ministers May,
may perform a [inaudible] ceremony,
but I don't think,
you know,
if you commit suicide,
it's really all that concerned that and how you view would be buried right
now.
So the question is why,
right?
The F the first unsaid is that some diligence prohibits a suicide more than
others is not very persuasive because order diligence prohibits suicide.
Well,
and here he comes with the idea of integration and he said that Justin does ms
less strongly integrated church than the Catholic Church.
Less of a community.
Um,
and uh,
Judaism actually even more directly integrated,
even more so of a community.
So therefore it leaves relatively little room for egoistic suicide because the
high level of integration and hear the rank order is relatively low level among
Protestants,
higher level among Catholics and particularly high among,
uh,
shows.
Well,
um,
how onerous gumps education into and the the picture,
well,
he says,
uh,
as,
the
common and costs,
costs,
costs.
Are Marie pleasure disease weakening that is an increase in the trend of
suicide?
Well,
it's not exactly prejudice in the most conventional sense of the term.
Uh,
what he's referring to a,
he's referring here to,
uh,
the question,
what kind of overcome with the education generally speaking,
right?
Um,
that if you are becoming more educated,
UVL have last off excepting doctorates,
right?
Education,
right.
Is a critical exercise.
Right.
And that's what I was trying to do in this course,
right.
To challenge you,
To be a critical theorist.
Right.
Do subjects your own consciousness to critical scrutiny and to subject the
theorists you have read to critical scrutiny.
Right.
That's why I asked you in the tests to do,
uh,
find a puzzle,
right?
And take CISE in this puzzle,
offer some criticism from some of the theories.
That's what education is all.
And therefore prejudice is dogma is declining,
right?
And if Dogma is declining that are less given stereotypes for us,
we believe in,
uh,
then,
beyond more likely to come with mid suicide.
This is a kind of weakening of the collective conscience is becoming more of an
individual consciousness.
The critical thinker is becoming more of an individual.
Um,
uh,
consciousness.
They'll end,
he said,
well,
they go together with religion because Catholic standard to be less educated
than Stratasys and more educated.
I don't know how much this still stands up to scrutiny,
but there certainly true that traditionally,
um,
artists than churches did attribute and greater emphasis,
uh,
to education.
One big reason was,
um,
uh,
the relationship between,
believers,
uh,
and uh,
and the clergyman,
right?
And the classical Roman Catholic theology like the clergyman interprets the
Bible,
right?
Uh,
for the believer believers,
the big right revolution of that formation was that they translated the Bible
right into native languages and printing was just made available and the started
to print the Bible and they wanted leap people to read the Bible.
Now in medieval Roman Catholic church,
only the priests read the Bible,
right?
Uh,
sort of Protestant is vent together with mass education,
massive public education and an emphasis on education.
How to read and write.
Alright.
Uh,
so therefore,
uh,
I think that that is a good,
good claim to be made on the long run.
And generally speaking,
Protestant tended to be more educated than Catholics.
I doubt,
you know,
whether you would find Marshall religious differences in contemporary societies,
but that was,
you know,
that,
VA was simply a correlation pointing into same direction.
Um,
and he,
he also makes this point,
which is by now utterly untrue,
Vema and are not less educated in advanced societies.
The man,
the men are actually by now more educated than man in the head once Western
countries,
including the United States.
Right.
In no time.
You guys,
you really have to very harder to make sure that you can catch up with the
ladies.
Right?
Because they will be better educated than him.
He'll be all right.
Uh,
but anyway,
and his times,
women were less educated than man and they were less likely to commit suicide.
I think there's also still the case,
I think for women are still less generally speaking,
still less likely to commit suicide.
In fact,
I think women are more likely to attempt suicide but completed suicide rate is
much higher among men than among women.
Right?
That's,
I think the basic finding.
But anyway,
here it's more of a methodological point.
I don't,
I doubt that whether the Catholic Protestant,
a distinction still stands and it's certainly,
it doesn't stand for women,
right?
Women by now,
um,
in the vest and advanced countries in almost every country are better educated
than men are,
especially the younger generation are better educated.
Um,
but the methodological point is interesting,
right?
As I said,
he's beginning to do multivariate analysis,
right?
So the dependent variable is tendency to suicide.
And he has a little,
you know,
regression model,
right?
He looks into the regression,
mother countries and gender and education and religion and trust to explain the
variance and the suicide rate.
Uh,
I mean,
uh,
in terms of research design,
this is very beautiful.
He done right.
This is social science,
right as we know it today.
Well,
and that is the Jew Judaistic puzzle.
Uh,
Jews,
I think there's still true is better educated.
They're non Jews.
Uh,
again,
I've wouldn't have survived on it.
I,
I really have not looked at data on religion and education,
but certainly generally has been true at,
at that time.
Uh,
then,
uh,
Durkheim was writing about the late 19th century.
Jews were a highly educated,
uh,
in European particular,
and by the 1920s and thirties in the United States as well.
Um,
uh,
do they are highly educated.
Uh,
well,
yeah,
less likely to commit suicide.
So there is a trouble,
right.
With his explanation of the model,
Uh,
what's going on here.
Um,
and then,
um,
he,
uh,
tries to understand what is the purpose of learning math.
You said the purpose of learning among Jews is different and that's the claim
Jews seeks to learn,
not in order to replace his collective prejudices,
but Millie do better arm for the struggle,
right?
So,
uh,
you'll read the Talmud,
right?
You go to the rabbi and you was through a all the kind of education to better
understand the holy scripture,
right?
And the interpretations of the Holy Scripture,
You've got a lot of education,
right?
If you are preparing yourself for your Bar Mitzvah,
We even have to learn Hebrew,
right?
To pass your bar,
Bar Mitzvah,
you sweat blood,
probably me.
And while doing so,
right?
Um,
uh,
this is not to challenge the doctrine.
It is to better understand the doc chain,
right?
And therefore he doesn't undermine the collective conscience,
these education strange,
the collective conscience.
Right?
I think that's at least Durkheim screen very,
again,
I think take it methodologically,
I think methodology call the formidable,
but this guy is doing a right as early as nine,
1897.
Right?
This is the kind of stuff today and if any one of you have,
you'll do a phd,
right?
In political science or economics or sociology,
you have the Candy Chi,
this kind of research design your mentor,
if you will say,
go for it.
That's the right way to do it,
right?
Anyway,
so that's uh,
so,
um,
uh,
now he says,
education.
Therefore it's a very interesting idea,
right?
You now does a kind of interaction,
I fact right between education and religion and he looks at this interaction
effect,
how these two affect each other.
They said it depends,
you know,
what education is all about.
You know,
education if it is v canning,
the collective conscience,
uh,
makes you just critical of everything.
What you learned a valuable to build the cause of suicide or devise is actually,
um,
uh,
important to,
um,
uh,
reinforce,
you are in society and now family and suicide.
And this is the point that I,
I did make,
right?
Um,
uh,
in fact,
you know,
if you are integrated in a sauce in,
uh,
you know,
family,
you are less likely to commit suicide.
And he said,
well,
uh,
there should be,
if that is true,
there should be some evidence that people who are married,
uh,
we'll be,
less likely to kill themselves and people who are unmarried and vidoe the,
and that is actually the case.
Uh,
uh,
generally by the way,
marriage seems to have a,
uh,
a house advantage,
right?
Uh,
uh,
if you are considering,
you know,
never to get married,
think about your health,
right?
Um,
uh,
if you,
if you get married,
uh,
statistics will tell you you will live longer.
And actually they also tell you you have your live happier than if you stay
along and now,
and you'll probably is less likely to commit suicide.
So that's what he called matrimonial immunity to suicide.
Why he says,
and this again,
incredible what he,
what the guy's doing here,
right?
He said,
well,
one possible explanation is that you know,
um,
because you know you are in a community right then for you,
you're not commit suicide.
I cannot due to my spouse to cure myself because my spouse,
your beam him or herself or my desks and I don't want to cause harm to my
spouse,
right?
Therefore I don't commit suicide.
I said,
young people often don't commit suicide.
The respect to,
uh,
to the their parents.
But he said,
and this is really extra ordinary,
he said that it can be caused by matrimonial selection,
right?
People who are more likely to commit suicide to begin with,
it may not marry.
Now,
those of you who took statistics classes,
you know what he's talking about though,
at that time,
this was not in statistics at all.
It is called the selection problem,
right?
This is exactly the selection problem.
He said,
we cannot really tell why people who are married are less likely to commit
suicide because it is possible.
People that intention to commit suicide are not get married,
right?
Because they are lonely people to begin with.
And this is why they did not marry.
So the lower frequency of suicide among married people is not the consequence of
marriage,
but marriage is the consequence of people's likely not to commit suicide.
This is the classic got example or discard the sample selection lawn,
right?
Um,
and the,
all the,
you know what the only solution for this is,
uh,
experimental methods,
right?
That's the only way how you could deal with this to solve the problem,
Um,
and if you,
uh,
Duke Feed Professor Green,
political science course,
you know exactly what I mean,
right?
Social scientists really should do experimental random assignments.
You could really come read of the problem of these,
uh,
sample selection bias.
If you could randomly assign people to get married or not to get married and
then they've,
you'll get married or not to get married and then to see whether it had an
effect or not.
Unfortunately,
in society,
we can't really do random assignments,
right?
The hardly can assign people to get married or not to get married and follow it
up 30 years later,
but that they are still alive,
right as the problem.
Uh,
but and advise that is really statisticians to all kind of big tricks around
this but really cannot be solved.
The real solution would be only the experimental metric.
There's nothing formal about this,
right,
that he is very ahead of himself.
You know,
I the whole problem of,
you know,
sample selection issue,
I came across this in statistics in the 1980s that's very,
it became a big thing.
The 1980s sample selection model,
how you control for the sample selection.
Grandma and he knew about the problem,
not the statistical album,
but the research design problem,
right?
In 1897.
Okay.
But he said,
well that is still data which supports actually,
uh,
that matrimonial Islam.
In fact,
they'll society the same.
That's counterintuitive.
He said if there are great social disturbances,
then actually social sentiment salad,
high revolution,
right.
You feel identified with your country and the revolutionary calls,
and you do not commit suicide.
If otherwise you would have committed suicide after suicide grade,
you'll be going down.
Uh,
so anyway,
uh,
um,
this was about egoistic suicide.
Now let me,
I am running out of time very badly.
Uh,
uh,
altruistic switch side,
there are touristic suicide is a happening then social integration is far too
high,
uh,
unbearably high.
And that's when people will be committing what he calls altruistic switch side.
Um,
uh,
the scan happen,
for instance,
he said,
uh,
people,
older man,
uh,
the example of what I gave,
you know,
the age,
uh,
commit suicide.
Um,
uh,
Vienen occasionally on the death of their husband commits suicide because they
think this is expected from them.
And traditionally after and followers or servants on the desk of the chief
committed suicide.
So,
uh,
we are talking about altruistic suicide because people commit suicide because
they think it is their duty to kill themselves.
Right?
Um,
and this is,
uh,
a sacrifice which is imposed by society for something like as social and right.
It can be obligatory in certain societies.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
if you lost a battle,
uh,
and you will a Japanese soldier,
right?
You committed hierarchy,
you know,
if you heard the general,
even in the Second World War,
they committed hierarchy,
killed themselves,
um,
uh,
or,
it actually can be even kind of mystical.
So he signed for instance,
uh,
as you know,
Hindus occasionally jump into the Ganga River to kill themselves.
Um,
well today he said this is a relatively rare incident,
but it happens in the army.
He says,
soldier skill themselves,
not because they are not sufficiently integrated.
What?
Because they are highly integrated and therefore that individual is,
is vague and that's why they've committed suicide.
And now,
um,
about uh,
uh,
anatomics suicide,
right?
Well,
you know,
anime,
anime is the lack of social regulation.
And indeed he said,
if you find yourself in ever changing situations where a value system is
changing,
you are likely,
uh,
to,
more likely to commit suicide.
Um,
uh,
and,
well,
it can be a reason for,
uh,
economic reasons.
So a traditional institutions decline a suicide during the Great Depression as
the bank,
uh,
um,
collapse of our street when people were jumping out of the window.
Uh,
it actually a few of the happened those so last fall with the turn down of the
stock market and it can be,
you know,
uh,
another good example is domestic and on me.
You get your spouse dies or you get divorced,
then,
uh,
suicide rate is recurrent.
And finally fatalistic switch side.
Um,
it,
as I pointed out,
a Durkheim notion of fatal is miss a twin concept to marks,
notion of alienation that is cool,
much that you relation and not enough social integration,
uh,
such as the keys off him,
slaves or childless women.
Uh,
then the turns to commit suicide.
There's about so,
so much about their time.
And so it's side
and Max Lecture,
I view it was dark too.
The questions briefly before we go on,
do a capsule methodology.
So they'll come,
you know,
they'll help full or the test.
Uh,
uh,
and I appreciate actually your class attendance.
It was wonderful.
All along.